[Musique]
d'où prédisposés génie de façon à avoir
une vie pleine et heureuse voici son
portrait fait par son ami le peintre
graveur bernard naud d'un génie tu vas
son était une forme de l'aristocratie
berrichonne qui descendent des grandes
familles des bertrand est aussi
descendent et c'est une jeune femme qui
va pratiquer la photographie mais
totalement en amateur c'est un
passe-temps qui deviennent passion ce
qui explique l'énorme production de sur
son travail
il ne reste malheureusement qu'une
partie de son oeuvre qui comporte quand
même sept mille plaques qui traduit son
talent j'ai dit tu vas sont parlées au
moins six langues et getti façon va
énormément voyagé
on fera beaucoup de deux photographies
réalisée plus tôt dans l'europe de
l'ouest mais également
dans les pays dans les pays du nord
génie de façon détestait son physique ce
qui n'a pas empêché de faire de nombreux
autoportraits
elle ne s'est jamais marié n'a bien sûr
pas eu d'enfant et est morte à l'âge de
48 ans en 1920 l'intérêt d'une façon
c'est que c'est aussi elle s'est
comportée en ethnographe donc elle a été
un témoin de sa génération elle était un
témoin de cette troisième république de
façon exceptionnelle
aujourd'hui outre les photographies sa
correspondance soutenue permet de mieux
cerner le personnage auquel plusieurs
auteurs ont déjà consacré des ouvrages